Anthony: Hey guys Anthony here for Dnews, in St
Petersburg at the Imagine Cup
A world young inventors competition. I
got Alex here with me from the Argentina
team.
You guys created something that I think
is
really really amazing. Tell me a little
bit about it. Alejandro: Our application is called uSound.
uSound is an application that takes
advantage of the phone's processing
capability to work
as at a digital aided program hearing aid. What it
does it lets people that has a
hearing impairment, instead of using the standard hearing aid
uSound with this
headphones which are much cooler. Anthony: My
father wears a hearing aid and it was like a
three thousand dollar hearing aid. How
much does it cost to use your phone as a
hearing aid?
Alejandro: Well our application costs three dollars
and ninety nine cents which is
a little bit less than that. Anthony: So tell me a
little bit about how it works. Alejandro: What
it does it lets you
input audiometrics test that an audiologist gave you.
Or if you don't want to you can go to a
quiet place and
do that uTest which basically does
the same that an audiologist does
but this is just an estimate. Afterwards
well uSound lets you like
correct the audio like
level it up and compensate all the
frequency that you have a problem. You attend a call
this would recognize which ear has been
used. Anthony: Whatever ear you put it up to it
corrects
the algorithm for that ear. Alejandro: If you want to listen to music
you could use the uSound player and
listen to
the music to your specific level. What
your way does is it lets you
sit anywhere in the classroom and leave the
phone whatever the professor says can
still listen. Anthony: How did you come up with the
idea? What made you guys wanna do this?
Alejandro: We have a friend of ours in
University and he was
actually really smart but he ended up
quitting University
because of his hearing impairment. We want
its
that people that has his problem where
we're able to a
keep studying. So that's why we
decided to implement
uSounds. Anthony: Tell me about Argentina and
the tech community there.
Alejandro: Well actually the tech community is
going up right now.
Alejandro: We are from a place, a really small
place called Cosquin in Argentina.
We have 35,000 people in there.
And this is the first time someone
from that place
actually does something for the
world. Anthony: That's awesome. Alejandro: We are pretty happy about
that. Anthony: What are you looking to get out of
the Imagine Cup?
Alejandro: We can get to finish up this project and
we can
put it in the whole world so that
people with hearing impairment can
get access in some solution like this. Anthony:
Excellent.
Well best of luck to you, Alex. And remember we have
more from the Imagine Cup
all week here on Dnews. There are so
many amazing inventions. Also,
amazing games. So go check out YouTube.com/rev3games
to see all the coverage about those.